recently there was a video going uh like
viral about a man a guy who was in uh
Mecca and he was shortless and he was
you know walking that you people equate
money to happiness and it's not it's
more freedom what people don't
understand is like once you have basic
needs met you don't get incremental
happiness for more money you do for a
short period of time believe that you
come to g s and insult me don't get
married until you're 35 making 6 fers a
year in shape going to the gym
consistently and have with 50 girls same
thing with pleasure pleasure is like
fleeting and pleasure is one of those
things where it's like it's a black
Hall alhamdulillah brothers and sisters
we've acquired the future Dean Center
property and we want to get the mashid
open first it's all coming along we're
installing the doors we can make woo
we've installed the carpets we have many
details to finish up but it's coming
along alhamdulillah we need a new roof
we need new windows and we need a minb
but that's right we need a minb but for
the musjid now if all of you want to be
a part of history and help build a house
of worship build the Masjid for the sake
of Allah so Allah the Creator can build
for you a house in Jenna click the link
below donate right now may God Almighty
Allah reward all of
you alhamdulillah Alum greetings peace
welcome to the Sham Med your host we got
a lot to talk about today Fitness
Nutrition being a high value man and
masculine Excellence purpose all of this
and more here with my next guest not one
but two we got manir and
[Applause]
Hussein let me introduce you to my
face we have one God name Allah
Allah and his final Messengers muhamad
peace be upon him this is our religion
Islam Islam this
the I love you work you're doing when I
was ready to talk about it I would only
talk to I was explaining how much
respect I have for the faith of
Islam so how you guys doing alhamd pleas
to be
here us nice to have you Brothers with
us so tell us um a little bit about
yourselves what you guys do I kind of uh
hit some topics that we're going to be
discussing kind of giving people a hint
Fitness uh masculine Excellence uh
purpose uh nutrition weight loss all of
these things so um if you want to start
from right to left absolutely inshallah
so my name is munir a fitness coach and
alhamdulillah I've been doing this for a
long time almost 10 years now uh
specializing in weight loss with Muslims
specifically so Al alah I've had the
opportunity to help a lot of Muslims
online through the modern Muslim man
which is a company I started fairly
recently actually in my journey so
alhamdulillah it's been a pleasure since
January 2022 to serve the umah and
alhamdulillah I appreciate the
opportunity to share with more of the
umah today my name is Hussein um born
and raised in Algeria moved uh to the
United States about 11 years ago
alhamdulillah my uh my journey has been
more like entrepreneurship wise um came
to the United States started as a
Wasington dishes and uh slowly and
surely grow into uh bodybuilding and
fitness as well used to be a coach in
the gym and then delve into a little bit
more content creation marketing and then
branding and then learned a lot more
about uh building businesses and the
backend systems software and all that
now alhamdulillah run a supplement
company also a uh Fitness and SL
masculine uh products we have and also
software company so that's kind of like
my journey in terms of what I do and
what I uh what I work what's the state
of the the community of analyzing I mean
know statistically they say that 70% of
just Americans in general are either
obese or
overweight and we're not uh far from
that we're not far from that at all
unfortunately and that's the thing is as
Muslims we have a lot of narrations from
the prophet peace be upon him that
should teach us uh to know better so
inshallah we're going to share some of
those today um but yeah we're right
about the saying about 70% of Muslims
are obese and it's unfortunate how it
affects a lot of the um so inshallah
we'll dive into that today um but yeah a
lot of Muslims are struggling with this
so uh with the right education the right
motivation and just following the
example of our Prophet sallu Al wasallam
should make a very big difference
there's actually a Hadith on this is it
uh one of the Hadith that you share it's
a it's a prophecy if you I mean there's
so many different proofs and evidences
for the prophet of prophet Muhammad
peace and blessings be upon him the
authenticity uh the Miracles the signs
in the Quran and since we're talking
about nutrition now and health and all
these other things we'll be touching
upon we mentioned the word obesity then
the prophet s you know about this
predict that uh obesity will be rampid
yeah there was uh one of the concerns of
the Prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
is the fact that a lot of people would
not be able to resist the Temptations of
their stomach and then obviously what
that leads to when it comes to your
ability to resist Temptations in other
areas especially with our Dean which is
the most important thing to us is making
sure that we're not transgressing
against God so um that's that's one of
the different uh narrations there's also
the Hadith which is you know sufficient
is a few morsels of food for the son of
Adam to straighten his back and if he
must fill himself onethird for food
oneir for water and one third to save
room for his breath but unfortunately a
lot of us over stuff ourselves far past
that point that's a big reason why we as
Muslims have an obesity problem and why
the whole world even outside of the
Muslim has an obesity problem but we as
Muslims if we just follow that one
Hadith it would make so much difference
when it comes to Bringing Down those
rates of obesity heart disease uh
cholesterol ol you know all the
different diabetes all the different
sort of epidemics that we have in our
community it really annoys me when I'm
when I walk into uh an event at a Masid
and you'll literally you'll see
doctors sitting across from each other
at a table and there's Pepsi corre
Coca-Cola I said man what's going on you
guys finished medical school yeah the
lack of following their own advice is uh
is astonishing and I think one of the
things too is we get into the world
where everything is um everything is
provided to us at the click of the
button but also more so than anything we
become more consumers than actually then
we produce things and we don't wait for
things to uh grow organically we rush
things and we exhaust the minerals and
the vitamins out of the soil right and
we continuously providing this chains
across the what the country that they
providing High processed sugar and they
or carbohydrates and then we have
unhealthy fats seeds oil uh we have
things that will cause inflammation in
the body and if we know know anything
about inflammation it will increase your
cortisol levels it will hinder your
testosterone Pro production per se for
man and also it will increase massively
the amount of estrogen in women so then
you have a man looking more like a woman
in a sense because then you're storing
visceral fat in your abdominal region
and then you have what they call them
love hand Les I don't think there are
any anything closer to that but you w
you walk into the Masjid and Subhan
Allah we were supposed to emulate the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam and
in one of the description of his body
his chest and his belly they were in
line even in a later age so and they
were they took on wrestling they took on
um uh they were warriors they were in
Wars they ate in moderation and even
through um his life sallallahu alaihi
wasallam he provided us even with the
best foods the remedies for things and
even in the Quran right for example we
take the uh the dates of the story of s
maram when she gave birth to our beloved
Prophet Jesus and Allah asked her to tap
on the the palm tree
so right she has dates come down and you
understand the value of dates and the uh
the PowerHouse of vitamins and minerals
that they have and even our prophet
wasam used to eat it's called the the
two blacks right the water and the DAT
so you can solely survive on those so if
we come closer and understand the the
nutrition from prophetic way I think we
have so much more value also staying
active we have uh Muslim Brothers they
just go home they are absolutely because
of the diet and the mindset I think
primarily too is that they go home they
are exhausted they have a bad attitude
about with their family bad attitude
about life and they just don't seem to
inspire even their kids their kids
became more infatuated by different um
different Role Models per se you get
your son calling let's say Batman or
Superman superhero when in reality you
supposed to call your dad's superhero
and then your dad supposed to emulate
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
and the sahaba those are supposed to be
our role models in every shape and form
but we have even today adults running
after let's say motivational speakers
who well they are not Muslims per se and
I think we should Cipher the information
that they give us and take the good but
I wouldn't put them in a on a pestal to
think that they are actually better and
intuitively if you follow someone and
they actually Captivate you emotionally
and maybe even your mind I think you put
him above someone who you shouldn't our
Prophet sallallah alaihi wasallam should
be on the top list of the people that we
should study and we should understand so
how important is it I mean when I when
that fact came came to me that and it's
not to pick on doctors we know you know
we love our brothers and and our
community members who are out there
serving in this area but it's all about
growth you know because you have a lot
of medical doctors who didn't learn um
nutrition in medical school that's just
a fact but then they grow and they get
inspired to learn more and then they end
up opening up a whole new world right
and they realize the importance now what
food plays because this is something
that they they really don't connect a
lot of times they just you know
prescribe the next drug whatnot just
masking the symptoms yes so how
important is it and back to what I was
saying what it really you know bothers
me because this is something that is
contributing to mental health uh the
Obesity heart dise all these chronic
diseases they say 95% of chronic
diseases are linked back to the for the
food the fake foods that people are po
choices yeah so how important how
important is this that we get this out
of the mass we get this out of our
fridge we get all of these fake
processed foods and I usually say fake
food is uh our foods with a list of
ingredients you need a biology degree
chemistry degree correct to even read it
to even read right so how important is
this when you just to really hit home
even more important in working out and
all this other stuff is the food that we
put in our to fuel our bodies this gift
that the creator has given us yes there
is actually a saying this is you can
never be able to outrun a bad diet no
matter how much exercise you do say that
again you would never be able to outrun
a bad diet no matter what you do there's
a lot of people who think because they
worked out they go home be like yeah a
soda is fine and then they will be like
yeah dut is fine because it's going to
spike my insulin perhaps and then you
will shove in all the nutrients that I
need but in reality it's more about the
nutrients dense food and that's what we
need we need to focus on eating
nutrients dense food like beef you got
lamb you got vegetables and and
specifically the things that doesn't
blow you and it doesn't hinder your
absorption for these nutrients and a lot
of people even in the fitness world and
in general everyone thinks in a
perspective of macronutrients and when
we talk about micronutrients we're
talking about protein carbohydrates and
fats and for us to really understand and
digest this concept or the nutritional
topic is that we need to understand they
divide into two categories that is one
is energy sources fats and carbohydrates
are energy sources and then carbohy uh
protein is a building block for muscle
tissue and for even uh organs and carage
right so we need that in particular more
so than we need the other things but in
order to survive and have a healthy
function of the brain the regulation of
hormones and all this systems to thrive
we need all these things but also we
need magnesium we need potassium we need
zinc we need all these vitamins and
minerals that they replenish
and help the neurotransmission of
information it helps with um the the
function of also organs the hearts and
even the uh produ production of hormones
as well and I think that's why nutrition
is a big topic when you go to a doctor
he's so adamant and quick to write you
down a pill well I I that's kind of like
the process of as you said masking the
symptoms but they would never address
the root let even go to injuries too
that's a different topic right but if we
say in the topic of nutrition they will
prescribe you a pill or they will tell
you to maybe Ease on something but they
would never for example smoking or they
would never ask you what would be your
diet for a month or what you eat they
would never customize you like a diet
they would never tell you to fast right
as Muslims we fast Mondays and Thursdays
is is a Sunnah from our Prophet
sallallah alaihi wasallam so that itself
will help your digestive system it will
eliminate bloating it will actually
improve your cognitive abilities it will
help um get rid of toxins and bad cells
in your body and now non-muslims are
actually catching up to it oh and theyed
fasting and then they do also 6 hour 16
hours fast and then they see the
benefits but for us we do that once a
year too we do 30 days right we flush
everything out and Subhan Allah it's
really rejuvenating yes you feel a new
man we have Ramadan right 30 days of
fasting and it's it's an amazing but
still people ruin it at night they will
go and they will indulge into desserts
that they are deep fried high sugar and
my brother munir can actually talk more
about it because you know he got some
brothers on on his plans and stuff and
he always coming up with healthy uh
diets and desserts and stuff like that
which is really interesting it's not
about I mean because it's a difference
so people understand like there's a
difference between the sugar and the
date because it comes with the fiber and
it comes with how Allah the Creator made
it it come it goes the body doesn't
destroy the body but we're talking about
this this uh sugar now that the
processed sugar that's pumped into over
half a million fake food items that out
there is destroying wrecking havoc on
the body and you're giving it to the
kids and also at the events and I I've
had some success where people were like
okay we started to like eliminate this
stuff we watched your program so
hopefully inshallah this can be a
catalyst for others
they don't it's just ignorance you just
don't know now after they listen to to
some health experts and they can see
like hold on man this is really cuz when
I myself I saw the harm that it was
doing to my body sugar once I cut that
out weight loss actually started to uh
become pretty easy MH and also Health
inflammation of the body and all the
other things you just um you start to
reap many benefits what do you have to
say about the sugar absolutely
absolutely so unfortunately sugar is
something that has infected a lot of our
culture obviously it's not from our
religion but a lot of times people
conflate religion and culture so in
Pakistani culture a lot of sugar and the
tea and the coffee all that stuff same
thing with uh with Arab culture you know
you'll see them just put like so much
sugar in the tea it's not even necessary
like at that point it doesn't even taste
good I don't know what's the daily
allowance they say even have you seen
where they shown in in Coca-Cola and
you'll see how what is it for one uh
gram it's like four teaspoons of sugar
what is it something like that so I mean
each each tablespoon of sugar
um I believe I mean it's it's it's it's
the quality of the sugar as well because
as you mentioned before it's the you
know inflammation everything else i'
have to check the exact amount in each
tables it's way whatever it's way above
what the health it's and and so one very
simple substitute that we can use like
for somebody who's just addicted they
have to have something sweet with their
tea just replace it with honey guess
what in the Quran and in the Sunnah we
know that honey is a medicinal food that
is beneficial for us obviously do like
real local honey raw un tampered with
honey exactly not like this fake honey
that's basically just syrup that tastes
like honey but just proper like you know
natural honey that's what we want and
that will make such a big difference
coconut palm sugar what do you think
about that um coconut palm sugar could
be potentially be beneficial Ian it's
definitely better than like just refined
sugar like that white table sugar that
we put Stevia could be good yes you know
in fact a lot of brother Hussein's
products are sweetened with stevia so
it's very helpful um for so there are
there are good substitutes there are
there are and and the advantage with
stevia is it doesn't have calories so
for somebody who's trying to actively
lose it helps them to actually bring
their calories down and get into a
calorie deficit the other uh downside
with sugar when it comes to creating a
calorie deficit is not only does it
increase your calories but it also will
cause you to crash your energy and then
when your blood sugar crashes and your
energy crashes you're going to move
around less burn less calories and get
hungry so you end up sitting around
eating more moving less getting your
body into storage mode and rapidly
gaining weight which happens to a lot of
Muslims and and I hear this argument oh
in moderation it's just like and then I
compare it to cigarettes like okay yeah
so give a kid a cigarette and just in
moderation one cigarette is not going to
do anything to the child right but it's
going to get them addicted so this this
sugar is what they've done uh I don't
know if you seen this documentary called
fed up I always recommend people watch
this do fed up and they they did scans
of the brain and they show that sugar is
actually more addictive than cocaine
cocaine it actually light up the same uh
part of the brain yeah one of the
actually downsides too of uh having so
much sugar is that you mentioned
something really important about fat
loss how you notice that your fat loss
actually drastically start improving
once you reduce the amount of sugar and
that goes actually to understand the
correlation between
insulin and also um the uh other
hormones that's in charge of mobilizing
and um oxidation of the fat once insulin
is down and that's where you always need
to make sure of every meal you eat I
give you an example one of the things
that uh every time you start to eat you
should never start with carbohydrates
you should never start with fat you
could but what's better is you start
with leafy greens vegetables and such
things then you follow up with protein
then you follow up with fat then you
have your dessert at the end even if
it's rice you eat them separately in
that order and that actually helps with
not spiking your insulin and Subhan
Allah Allah created in such a way that
once the food touches your stomach or go
through it actually has mechanism to
recognize what it is so we actually
start the digestive process at an early
stage so we knows what it needs to
release and if you put sugar it tells
the body okay we're getting a load of
this sweet stuff let's Spike insulin
because we need to shove it inside the
cells but if you start with leafy greens
that doesn't happen because leafy greens
don't have that much of simple sugar
another thing that our brothers can
actually do is take a 10-minute brisk
walk walks after you eat it's good for
your digestion helps you with your
insulin uh as well and it doesn't it
helps really keep a cap on that amount
of insulin another thing is fasting it's
amazing that once you fast your insulin
sensitivity improves drastically a lot
of people will be like okay it's
lunchtime but I don't want to eat okay
why oh because I fall asleep it's
because your insulin resistance if you
fast two days in a row right of course
from sunrise to sunset you're your
cognitive ability also you will eat and
you would not feel tired actually will
Empower you everything is getting
absorbed everything is getting digested
correctly and then to mention there is a
recent news about aspiran in uh um zero
zero Coke right and they always be like
yeah yeah I want to get the zero Coke
but people don't understand even if he
has zero calories I tell you another
sweetener that is um that is dangerous
the same as aspan is sucr lose right it
cause an alteration in your gut biome
and if you alter that that means that
you're increasing your cortisol that
means your insulin is getting increased
and then you are actually lowering your
testosterone but more so the
neurotransmitters they're not like
serotonin is produced in the gut so
neurotransmitter is actually important
for uh daily function and for you to
focus and for you to actually be healthy
so you can see the ramification of
actually using fake sugars but another
thing is creating I mean you can see
even obese kids right parents are that's
an epidemic now yes and hug and parents
are irresponsible in such a way very
irresponsible yes and they bring Coke
and then in even in um Islamic
Gatherings they will bring let's say a
lot of bread they will bring a lot of uh
Coke and they bring let's say a lot of
rice right that's absolutely overcooked
which is actually worse cuz not even
that the donuts and all of the uh pizza
pizza and all this other stuff Fried
Chicken Fri everything yeah you know uh
one thing I want to expand on with the
topic of like fiber and kind of like
layering your stomach making sure you're
eating things in the right order and
then also tying in with the whole
concept of like spiking your insulin
because like for instance we mentioned
before like with fruits because there's
the fiber with the sugar it's going to
hit your bloodstream slower so you're
going to get less of an insulin Spike
and again there's a lot of downsides to
having these huge insulin spikes because
then your blood sugar crashes you get
hungry uh you get tired all these
different things versus and then
obviously that contributes to the
problem with diabetes that we have
because not only you're becoming obese
from all the fat that you're storing
from all that sugar and Insulin spikes
and all those calories but and then the
excess consumption but also causing
insulin resistance which is why so many
Muslims have type 2 diabetes especially
you know in the Pakistani population
Arab population we're genetically prone
to these things so on top of that when
we're eating unhealthy it causes a lot
of issues but simply by making the
shifts to carbs that have a lower
glycemic index and putting fiber and
protein in our stomach before the sugar
hits so it slows down to digestion which
is going to lower the sort of glycemic
index the glycemic Spike of those carbs
in our system makes a huge difference my
uh my nutrition has made this slogan and
I often repeat it because sometimes
times people can get very um intimidated
by some of these words and a lot of
these things are over their head it
seems confusing unless someone starts to
until somebody gets to the next level or
gets into it so we often say real simple
what do you guys think eat real food
avoid fake food absolutely it's like the
white belt level cuz we can get deeper
into all the different yes if it doesn't
if it doesn't have a label eat it as an
egg so how would you define that that's
a good one right there eating real food
avoiding fake food is what if it does if
it doesn't have a label eat it for
example an egg doesn't have a label yeah
we understand it has a shelf life but it
wasn't stamped it wasn't mixed in it's
literally you took it from the the the
under the chicken and then you put it in
a that's it this is interesting this
opens up a whole different conversation
because there been there's been some
push against it but eggs but this is one
also a very healthy food right it's one
of the best one of the best what about
this whole thing when you ask and we're
talking about free range we're talking
about organic we're talking about
healthy right what about when you hear
this argument also now that it can
increase cholesterol and all this lot of
some myths that revive revolve around
eggs which eggs is very healthy so you
know what I would say is there's foods
that are healthy but obviously if we
consume anything in excess it's going to
be a bad thing because we also need to
be mindful about the quantities it's
about quality and quantity right so if
we're eating excess of anything like I
mean I guess it would be kind of hard to
eat like too many cucumbers or too many
carrots or whatever but even if you eat
too many dates it's a healthy food but
you're going to end up just the the
total glycemic load the total amount of
sugar in those dates even if it's you
know less bad than you know eating a
tablespoon of sugar it's going to be too
much so with eggs as well uh eggs
definitely get a bad wrap and if
somebody has really really high
cholesterol and they just had a heart
attack all that stuff maybe don't eat
like 10 eggs a day right but at the same
time uh getting eggs into your diet can
be highly beneficial and brother hosin
actually has a lot of knowledge on this
topic as well what about the healthy CH
there's the healthy cholesterol that you
so I I I think that a lot of even
doctors actually heart doctors there is
a heart doctor who just wrote a book
about um heart attacks and why people
get them and he noticed that uh young
people are start getting heart attacks
and he said okay is it bad cholesterol
how these plages are actually built up
in the arteries and all those areas
where they pump in Blood and then they
get strokes and he realized that the
issue it was not actually the
cholesterol because what's what are the
hormones like for example what's the
uh the makeup of testosterone it's a
cholesterol right so cholesterol is not
bad and fats are not bad the right fats
are actually really good for you and you
should do you should use them fats helps
you absorb nutrients it helps you to
regulate your hormones which if you have
a lack on any of those you're actually
going to live either depressed you're
going to feel lethargic all the time and
some even suffer the um some other
performance right you're not going to be
performing any your Peak at all time but
sugar is actually the main cause because
when sugar is at what it does because of
the arteries they they have layers and
actually the sugar start damaging those
layers then what happen the body is so
smart it tells the calcium and the
cholesterol to go seal and repair then
you get plages then if you don't fix it
it continue then you get one slips off
and that's what happened in the stroke
uh before we shift um to another topic
tell me what message would you give to
to the
local board members or people who make
the decisions or people bringing in the
food you know after after juma's over or
something and then you have people lined
up selling uh Coca-Cola giving pizza or
giving uh Donuts uh candies uh to to
kids and whatnot what advice would you
give and what substitute one time I I
actually came into uh when they were
giving out candies I came in and I
brought all these different varet of
different fruits and stuff dates and
that and I said what this is better to
give them you started to educate them a
little bit what advice so hopefully they
can take this and run with it so they
can be because the detrimental effects I
mean it's very very like you said severe
with the uh obesity in children kids are
suffering tooth decay at such a young
age right from the sugars and all the
other health disasters and even
self-esteem as well because that's going
to be affected looking in your mirror
and you're just fat and you know and
you're not probably connected maybe some
some mental health issues due to this
also so what what what advice would you
give from to get this uh out of the
massage and replace it so to the local
mjid who's feeding the children donuts
and sugar and bringing Pepsi and you
know all this even the pop the machines
the vending machines yes there's
unhealthy food even in the vending
machine there's all these chips and
Cheetos and whatnot that these kids
become addicted to and accustomed to and
then they're eating them as adults when
they definitely can't afford to eating
them but even as kids we're getting
obesity uh again what I'd say to the
local mjid is remember the health of
your Community is going to make such a
big difference as far as the quality of
our I when we're worshiping right
because I think that's the biggest thing
is the community wants the the Majid
wants people to be connected to the
community feel good and ultimately
please Allah right please God is
ultimately our purpose for everything so
we're going to worship Allah better if
our energy levels are good from eating
healthy foods so replace you know the
donuts with fruits like you said the
fruits are healthy they're sweet and
maybe somebody who's addicted to eating
like 10 Donuts a day is going to need a
couple weeks to get used to eating fruit
but once they do they'll prefer it
because they're going to feel better
they're going to have energy they're
going to actually feel good instead of
being bloated tired inflamed all the
time same thing with a lot of our dishes
that we make as Muslims uh in our
different cultures Pakistani Arab
whatever it may be uh we can easily make
a very similar tasting dish a lot
healthier by not putting excessive oil
in it and by using higher quality oils
instead of putting like canola oil and a
lot of this junk that we put in absolute
garbage process causes inflammation
everything else you know there are some
scientists who say oh you know it's not
that bad but look the way it's process
the way that they use toxic compounds to
extract the canola from the plant Etc
it's very bad for you most people will
notice if you just switch off canolo
you're going to feel a lot less inflamed
versus if you add it back in you feel
very inflamed so switching to olive oil
which is the Sun that the thing that our
profit piece be upon Him recommended is
going to be so much more beneficial
using you know natural grass-fed butter
and ghee and using it in appropriate
quantities where we're not loading it
with a ton of calories keeping the the
food a little bit less calorie DSE
putting a little bit more protein High
Quality Meats high quality proteins
grass-fed beef organic chicken even
telling the Halal Farms to start
treating the animals right because you
know if you're going to slaughter the
animal right you should also raise the
animal right give it good food don't be
giving the animals steroids go to like
the the Halal food store and the chicken
breast are enormous because they pumped
it with steroids they pumped it with all
kinds of hormones so again message to
the masjids when we prepare these Foods
let's prepare them homecooked to Muslim
restaurants let's not loaded up with so
much oil let's make it taste good with
high quality ingredients to the Farms
let's not pump the Animals full of
hormones let's follow the Sunnah and do
what pleases God what pleases Allah the
most which is to treat the animals right
to treat the community right to give the
community good wholesome food Allah
tells us in the Quran consume the good
Wholesome foods and do not commit excess
Allah does not love those who Comm
commit excesses those who are excessive
so again it comes down to the portion
control from the Hadith from the Quran
it comes down to the quality of the
foods and it comes down to you know
practical solutions for the mids swap
out the sweets for fruits swap out the
bad oils for good oils adjust the
quantities so the food has a little more
protein a little more fiber a little bit
less excessive fats and carbs everything
else we can still eat carbs it's fine
just stick with those you know like
basmati rice in moderate quantities is
very good especially when having with
fiber and protein it's not going to
spike your blood sugar the way that you
know a lot of these high sugar or high
GIC carbs are going to affect it so
again those Natural Foods is going to
make a massive difference in the prophet
had talked about the two things that
people take for granted the most is
their time and health yes and this is a
Priceless gift from our creator from God
Almighty Allah and this is the way
inshallah our spiritual side working on
it through Salah through the pillars of
Islam and all the other things that been
prescribed for us also to get this to be
a holistic individual this is something
that's so important is the nutrition the
fuel that we put put in our body 100%
there's one Ayah from the Quran that I
always reflect over you know when it
comes to this topic in
Surah verse 172 where God Almighty Allah
is
saying and people just kind of just
gloss all over this why is the creator
Allah saying oh you who
believe uh eat of
theat you know this is you know goodness
the good organic pure back then it
wasn't called organic it was just Foods
the real foods why is Allah mentioning
this this is this is something you know
in in the midst of all the other things
that are mention he's instructing us to
eat good food absolutely and to actually
really inject something more to P
perspectively to the non-muslims is that
when we talk
about it's more like the goodness that
we have given to you and Allah told us
to not eat other things for example I
would say the alcohol is a fermented
whatever uh uh you got the wine you got
the all all you have the pork right and
the reason why we don't eat it it's not
only because it has scientific and all
that stuff we can dive into those but
it's Allah gave us all these options and
tell us not to do this one thing so
always goes to um instant
gratification I think as Muslims we have
to understand and emulate the test that
Allah puts upon us that we're in this Dy
to be tested we're in this D to be put
in front of us things that Allah said do
not do and we will be rewarded later on
with jna insh it's the same thing apply
at a micro level when you go and you see
a donut don't eat it you got to think
about what it's going to do but if you
are just driven by desire and you just
fall for anything and everything
Therefore your mindset is flawed and you
would not you at a greater scheme I
would say maybe you're even failing the
bigger test M right so when you when you
follow that frame of Standards you will
be really understanding the
ramifications of your decision at a
micro level because they actually
somehow represent the mcro level which
is your mission as Allah
said oh I didn't create the Jin and the
ins the uh the the humans the mankind
just to worship me and that is actually
the true Essence in a mission of someone
and the body is in am and we have to
take care of it right and we have to do
everything that we can to be functional
to be always in a good State and we have
to also as you mentioned something
really interesting a lot of people have
this uh too long to read right right now
be like oh he's talking about nutrition
he mentioned so many hormones he
mentioned this micronutrients man I have
no time for that I I need to make money
but re believe it or not if you dive
into nutrition and you understand that
you probably running driving a car with
hand breaks up because your nutrition is
broken you're not going to end going
nowhere your engine is going to suffer
your brakes and all these things and I
don't think anyone in IR rational mind
to drive their car with a hand brakes up
right so understand nutrition read books
read books understand watch podcast
about nutrition try because not
everything's going to work for you te do
test for your blood there is a book
that's called eat based on your blood
type if you're B positive maybe you are
hyper sensitive to certain things your
blood reacts differently to different
nutrients you need to understand that
there is also other diets that are
really based on performance optimal
digestion they will help you massively
in uh getting the most out of your day
and I believe that a Muslim should be
functioning at zero or 100 zero is
sleeping 100 is every day you cannot
afford to be a functioning at 50 because
you're going to be hurt you're not going
to take the most out of your time and as
you said the two things are food and
wasting time right and time wasting so
if we take advantage of those two things
you would not be tired at all you always
be function yes we all have pits and I'm
not saying that you have to be rigid
about it you can treat yourself here and
there with a healthy dessert right and I
think finding that balance is really
important the balance is not that as you
said if I give you one cigarette a day
it would not make a difference I think
the mindset of you have to do what I
like to call it amplifying the situation
therefore you understand the magnitude
and the ramification of your actions for
example if I'm going to eat one donut
what would it do if I eat a thousand
Donuts in a n is like in in would it be
beneficial the answer is no okay then
one is going to harm me as Allah subhana
said about the alcohol right
in the
few more like the the the whole the
bigger quantity it will be harmful to
you and maybe you will have
benefits like small benefits here and
there but it will be dismissed because
of the grand scheme of things because
it's harmful and that's kind of like the
approach is magnifying the U realization
of that thing same thing goes actually
for weed for all these things that a lot
of people are not thinking is a big deal
and fixing your nutrition is a top
priority and it's it's from the it's
from the Quran the first a he
says and then once he our Prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam digested the
the information for quite a bit then he
says
so uh stand up and go and uh preach to
people but also the a after that insens
vised him to start with himself right to
clean his rope to uh stay away from uh
ill speech and all those things
so Allah would never change the
situation of uh of a group of people
until the change starts within and
that's where we have to come to
understand nutrition you have to take it
a serious thing because then you're
going to pass it down to your children
and your children and then you you
building a thriving Community a strong
umah and that's where we truly should
aspire to be absolutely and we're
building that Foundation now be holistic
human beings holistic Muslims so we have
um this topic we've touched upon it
nutrition very important before we get
into also and this this this is about
being a high value man all of these
things good hygiene good appearance good
nutrition uh making sure you're praying
five times a day making sure you're
connected to your creator and next part
we're talking about is working out and
I'm sure you've heard of Arnold
Schwarzenegger and uh Ron Ronnie you
heard of Ronnie yeah Ronnie Coleman
Ronnie Coleman I want get your reaction
to this um looking good Ronnie warming
up there looking good believe that you
come to Gorge Sim and insult me right
off the top saying is this your War up
boy I mean what is going on
here for you this is the war B for me
this is the ultimate we when I saw this
I was like um the first thing I was like
wow this is a seven or eight time
Olympian Ronnie and I think I don't know
if he's just going through an injury
what's happening when he's on crutches
now so the tricky thing with Ronnie
Coleman is he trained very excessively
heavy and he's publicly admitted this I
mean all these guys do take steroids
right and so when you're taking
substances that make you unnaturally
strong beyond what your joints are
designed to be able to handle I mean you
can train your joints and strengthen
your joints but Ronnie Coleman I mean he
squat like 800 lbs for reps was
deadlifting 800 lbs for reps mashah
right um but at the same time you know
by putting so much stress on his body
doing that like a couple weeks out from
the Olympia when he was super depleted
from his training from his diet
everything very very dangerous lots of
damage so he's got like a bunch of fused
vertebrae in his spine he's had tons of
surgeries hip replacement everything so
that's why he's on crutches and for him
he actually regrets nothing because he
said it was worth it everything else I
mean I think most people wouldn't find
that to be worth it but everybody can
make their own decisions of course so
it's important I mean back to the Quran
verse uh do not commit excess right so
we can take that lesson that Allah lot
teaches us in one area of our life and
apply it to others it's not just
nutrition it's training it's any area
you don't want to be excessive and
unbalanced and so if you end up really
overstressing your body and wearing it
out not taking care of injury prevention
very very important even a lot of people
who are very diligent with their
exercise diligent with their nutrition
amazing physique amazing Fighters
amazing athletes do not take care of
their mobility and injury prevention and
that's a whole another topic we can dive
into and even when it pertains to our
Dean you don't want to be somebody who
ends up being stuck in a chair praying
when you're older and of course it is
but we still need to do our part to do
our best to make sure that we're taking
care of our body so that doesn't happen
and so we're minimizing the chance same
thing with any condition we may have and
again we have to take the ownership on
ourselves and not just blame but be the
one who because a level change of people
when they're willing to change
themselves but at the same time you know
same thing when it comes to our body not
over injuring ourselves and overusing
the different parts of our body so
that's how old are they about now in
their 70s 80s uh Arnold's in his 70s
Ronnie's only in his 50s or 60s he's
he's only in his 50s or 60s so one thing
from a different angles uh seeing this
is they're still working out yes correct
still working out H yeah yeah I I I
actually used to work out a Golds Gym
and I think Ronnie happened to him is
that that's a gy this is actually is
called the me gold gy the mecca yeah
that's what it's Mecca of yeah meca of
bodybuilding Mecca of bodybuilding oh
it's Mecca bodybuilding in ven meca of
bodybuilding is yeah gold okay Mecca of
bodybuilding so did you ever use to see
them there yes I yes yeah yeah have you
met have you met I met Arnold you met
Arnold SP yes I met Arnold yeah I met
other few top bodybuilders as well yeah
yeah cuz that was some sort of the
business that I used to run in terms of
like filming and all that and content
creation I think also the the the
combinations as brother M said the uh
exogenous hormones that they they use
and they abuse in a way but also it's
not so much about just doing heavy
lifting we have to understand and I
think that is a recently there was a
video going uh like viral about a man a
guy who was in uh Mecca and he was
shortless and he was you know walking
was that
you no no would never do you're not you
weren't the guy in the no I would never
do such thing uh but I think
bodybuilding in itself just alone and
not having the ability to um to defend
yourself and fight and as you guys have
here a jiujitsu uh gym and striking gym
as well mallah is actually you prepare
yourself for a situation where you be
able to fight you would be able to
defend your honor or your family and I I
think just doing bodybuilding in its own
and neglecting the other aspect let's
say Mobility self myof fascia release
which is just you massaging yourself and
you releasing the mus nutrition as well
which is really important about that as
well uh you have to be a multifaceted
individual so you can be actually a
hybrid uh athlete in a sense so you need
to be able to fix things uh make sure
you're stretching all the time not just
bodybuilding I believe that these
individuals who are suffering like R ni
colmer right now because they didn't
take a holistic approach to the sport a
lot of people are going to come after me
saying like who are you to say this
because you got no Mr olympas and all
that stuff but I mean you see him he can
even walk what kind of quality of life
and actually I know him I know his his
injuries really well and I listen to his
podcast he's always nine out of 10 in
pain even when he does his life now day
consists of just nine out of 10 pain and
it's not one out of 10 this is nine n
out of 10 10 is like the Maxum and he
would sometimes go even it's 12 out of
10 so that means he's probably taking
painkillers painkillers he has to uh
literally his mind always thinking is
just the pain about the hips I mean he
can even comfortably get in and out of
the car that's a whole different topic
of the addiction of painkillers what is
altering your mind your neurons all this
other stuff that's happening in your
body AB yes wow and they're widely
prescribed to to everyone who think they
are actually stuck in a rut and feeling
depressed what was your reaction since
you brought up this this video that went
viral with the the brother there in
Mecca yeah yeah yeah what was your guys
reaction to that so it's interesting
because obviously you know we always
want to assume the best of our fellow
Muslim but at the same time that's not
the appropriate place to be you know
flexing the gains and whatnot um but I
think the other thing too is you know H
and I were talking about this and it's a
huge topic which is that bodybuilding
can sometimes breed a degree of
narcissism and again I'm saying and
assuming nothing about our brother he's
our brother in Islam I want to assume
the best um but but it is a pattern that
Hussein and I have both noticed being
around bodybuilders is that it breeds
this unhealthy level of narcissism in
addition to that as Muslims our goal
with Being Fit is not for the sake of
vanity of course it's great to look good
and say mallah when you see yourself in
the mirror and to give Allah credit for
giving you the blessing and the
potential of opportunity to build a
great physique but we as Muslims we do
this because we want to take care of the
am the trust that Allah has entrusted us
with with our body and when we do it for
that sake there's Baka in it there's
blessings in it because we're seeking to
become closer with God and to please God
to please Allah by building our bodies
taking care of our health we're not
doing it for the sake of narcissism or
self- glorification because that could
even lead to minor sh right when we're
putting ourselves on a pedestal when in
reality we need to be humble and instead
you know realize that God is infinitely
greater than we as human beings could
ever be good point good point so how how
important is it now to along with good
nutrition on a basic level some people
are not going to be able to um get to
that level that they're in the gym five
six times a day but basic stuff we're
talking about for the basic person even
many of the imams might be watching the
sh and they looking down and they're say
man I feel bad people not taking me
serious I got to get rid of this
pregnant belly you know I'm not a woman
and I got look I got twins here so what
basic stuff they could they do from
getting up and just walking speed
walking maybe some push-ups he can't
even do one yeah right so what basic
stuff that then it can slowly build up I
think one of the most why is it why is
it so important it's so important to to
to continuously move in through life so
you can maintain a healthy body another
thing too is that there is a
misconception and you actually mentioned
it you said that people cannot do 6 days
a week at the gym and actually that's
not the right approach to go about
training if you study the pro the the
life of the prophet sallallahu alhi
wasallam and also the sahabah they did
not per se train every day yes they were
in war they were moving every day they
were walking they had a different
lifestyle they didn't have even within
Mecca they didn't just hop or medina
they just just hop on the horse and go
from just from here to there but in
today's time people are not even willing
to take steps and walk or take the
stairs they will take the elevator right
and they be like yeah I don't want to
sweat or anything like that or they will
even refuse to go to the gym because I'm
tired but it starts with actually just
putting your shoe in the door and be
like okay tomorrow I'll just take a 5
minute walk after a meal and training in
to see results one thing that you need
to do is that you just need to go to the
gym 30 minutes will be fine if you go
train with intensity and the correct one
you understand the form you're not going
to hurt yourself and you learn your body
as you go and that's the beauty of it
and you will appreciate it and you
actually will bring you closer to Allah
to realize I have these all intricate
amazing mechanisms in my body this is
didn't happen just out of the blue this
is not a just a a bang bang and we were
monkeys and we evolved into human beings
and you all this like ideology that they
have into Evolution you understand that
there is a Creator there is a designer
who
actually created us in a beautiful way
that we function so to Circle back to
the tips just do three days a week just
pick the time after fud go for a run
lift something heavy lift it fast make
sure you're stretched you're warmed make
sure you are recovering well a lot of
brothers don't take recovery when people
think about recovery which is not their
aspect that's really important besides
nutrition and training which majority of
i' says channels don't really talk about
is that they think recovery is just
chilling grabbing your phone and
overindulging in Netflix or uh social
media no true recovery is actually
flushing out those toxins right and the
toxins that they help you to perform cor
it helps you to survive so you have to
take ice bath you have to do which is
which is wet cupping I know a lot of
people be disgusted by it but you have
to do it every three three months hijama
hijama yes hij it's almost let's revive
this Sunnah this is so important yes you
literally will feel that your your
lighter you sleep better you're
cognitive your ability you perform you
think better and you feel better also
what's more important is that you
emulate in the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam so you have a on it as well and
you can see the the I actually posted a
lot of those videos in my in my uh my
page that you can see the red and the
clutters and the gases and the white
plasma dirty stuff yellow so it's really
disgusting but you will feel amazing
doing it and a lot of people don't even
take the time and this actually circling
back to the
colesterol uh topic because we are
eating all these processed foods and
then it's being just being in the body
but if you flush it out through doing
hijama it will help you massively and
you can see the change in your body so I
love it what was the other thing uh you
recommended ice bath ice you can do
sauna you can do acupuncture as well MH
yeah you can even you like the ice bath
I love it yes yes every week I do it
twice if now I'm thinking about doing it
every night before sleep or you can how
long how long do you get into the cold
water what do you do 5 minutes is good
minutes is good five minutes is good yes
and then after a workout if there is a
sauna on your gym go in the sauna has a
great healing properties it will help
you to actually produce some protein as
well in the body a lot of studies on the
on the sa of the hot cardiovascular
health Improvement right yes growth
hormone increase testost increase it's
an amazing also you flush out toxins
through your skin which is the biggest
organ in the body yeah and it and it
lowers the risk of you know heart attack
it's there's a strong correlation
between frequent Sona use and lower risk
of heart attack so this is very good uh
but I wanted to actually expand on the
topic of like uh steps for like you know
maybe some of the imams and brothers and
possibly sisters as well who are looking
down and feeling like hey I need to make
some little steps but I'm not sure with
exercise you know what are Little Steps
so brother Hussein mentioned like even
the littlest step like having your
workout clothes ready to go will kind of
prime your brain to reduce that
resistance point and be able to start
taking little actions but building a
little routine right walking is one of
the best ways to just start getting into
working out so again like a lot of uh
individuals who might not be able to do
a push-up or you know even individuals
who have never worked out in their life
and now they're in their 50s and 60s and
they can't necessarily build muscle very
quickly because again uh time is working
against them but they still know they
need to do something about their health
starting with just the walking starting
with just a little bit of body weight
movements at home some isometrics
meaning exercise where you just hold a
position position to build that Baseline
strength can make a very big difference
and we just expand all those things even
a lot of individuals in their 20s 30s
40s people who are younger who can build
muscle faster we can still start to take
those little baby steps with some body
weight training at home with some basic
steps with walking nutrition everything
else getting in your protein intake and
once we just build an easy sustainable
Rhythm whether it's 5 minutes a day 10
minutes a day 20 30 something small that
we can do every day that enriches us
like we were talking about before it's
not going to take time and energy away
from your other priorities in life it's
going to give you more time and energy
you're going to take off the the brake
and finally be able to drive at full
speed and put the right fuel in your
body that God gave you because when you
get loaned a car and you put the wrong
fuel in it's not going to run properly
when you put the right fuel in it and
you take care of it and you service the
engine and you give it its you know due
maintenance hijama can be kind of like
your oil change right um that allows
your body to function so much better
which allows you to make so much more
out of your day like josein said so
those little steps of the walking some
isometrics all these things these are
some steps that I've used with some of
the sh who have come to me who are in
that position or even you know
individuals from all walks of life who
just want to start building that
Baseline Fitness and start to get that
ball rolling inah yeah and I like this
analogy where you're going through life
with the parking brake on mhm or you got
the Band-Aid on the check engine light
yeah and you're not solving the root
problem and the the other thing I took
away from this was when I saw them two
of some of the great bodybuilders of all
time right Arnold Schwarzenegger but you
can see now that their life you see how
uh both of them you're and I didn't know
this he's just his life okay he spent a
good portion of his life and he enjoyed
and whatnot but now what what does he
have if it's not built on true purpose
in life Arnold Schwarz is same thing Mr
Olympia how many seven seven times
Ronnie eight is it eight times okay you
had the things that uh you accomplished
and people praised you and whatnot but
now people are forgetting about you
Ronnie who I didn't know who he was
really and he's in pain he's on crutches
if you're not living for if you're just
your whole life is just about working
out and it breeds like you were saying
this narcissism and whatnot and you
didn't connect with your Creator and now
the weights are staying behind MH and
absolutely there's another Point too it
chips away from your masculinity MH
because a a person a man I would say per
se who is very interested in massively
how he looks and there are people who
are going to look good and there are
people who are actually almost checking
themselves in the mirror all the time I
lose an inch here I'm here and they they
pay they pay meticulous details to kind
of like how they look they fall in the
Trap of actually becoming effeminate
because a woman is the beauty you know
side of the equation if we talk about
let's say uh the masculine and The
Feminine CU feminine are intriguing to
the way you look at this is why we are
asked to lower our gaze but a masculine
man almost doesn't care so much about
how he looks but he should take care of
himself as brother M earlier said about
the Hadith we should not take one in
linear we have to see the collection
what they say for example there's AI
that
says right the strong believer is better
than the weaker believer and this could
be even in IM or could be in physical
right but there is another Hadith when
our Prophet sallallahu Alam walked on
the sahabah and he found them wrestling
inside the Masjid not he was bothered by
the fact that they were wrestling but he
wanted to teach them a lesson and then
he knew he saw what they were doing but
he insisted to ask what are you guys
doing and then they said ohas we're
we're wrestling and to see who's the
best man who's who's the real man and he
said the real man is the one who can
actually control his anger and this is
goes into like how to actually control
your emotion as a man but some brothers
be like yeah so if I control my anger
I'm good I'm set no what about the other
Hadith
that's right so you have to somehow take
everything in correlation not in linear
and we see a lot with a lot of Tik Tok
uh I would say or you know those
Instagram that they take one thing and
they just kind of like okay look at this
okay did you study the dean did you
understand the whole uh uh the whole
Hadith that surrounds that topic because
the
prophet had one thing to say about that
situation but then he teaches them as
they went through life he didn't just
sit down was like okay this is the deal
all of it this is the book I got you
guys the book follow the book no even
Allah subel prepared us from Adam until
Prophet until our Prophet Sall alaihi
wasallam so everything was gradual even
the revelations came slower and slowly
through that so we have to understand
the collection of a Hadith and the we
should not take things linear in a way
so so we we covered a lot of things that
go into making a masculine man and
nowadays in this what do they call the
manosphere what is the manosphere the
manosphere red pill red pill you hear
these things so this is kind of
connective you got some things in there
to talk about you know working out talk
about how masculinity and burden of
performance and all these other thing
Concepts that are there we we spoke a
little bit off camera that you've also
indulge a little bit in reading or
you've yes a lot of this material yeah I
do in a lot of books about uh the um
let's say one of the books was the
rational male there is series there are
five and then I read a little bit about
um uh Cooper um entrepreneurs in cars
he's another guy too but all they what
was your what was your takeaway from all
you read a lot of the books what was
your takeaway at the end I I think they
they really analyze certain um situation
and they are to where we they call the
inter seexual Dynamics and it's almost
like uh and they explain it as it's
being a prology not an ideology or
anything like that because it's ever
evolving into observing and uh some sort
of like taking notes on human behavior
and how the two Sexes actually uh
interact and one of the things that they
focus on in terms of the high value man
as you mentioned is that the man has to
uh sleep with as many women and he needs
to have experience and another thing is
um the B burden of performance what I
would like what I would think that they
assessed the certain phenomenon and
situations and issues correctly but the
dis the the description of the issue is
correct the prescription is what's
flawed because you are creating the same
issue that you are actually trying to
run away from because if you are telling
men focus on your purpose but then you
telling them sleep with as many women as
possible then how is that those are
actually contrary in a sense because a
man focusing on his on his purpose would
not have distractions and should not
right and if you have like Islam
prescribed the solution for man get
married and get married early do not
wait if you find the the the right
spouse you vet her correctly her father
accept your father everyone is good and
you agreed marry marry them even I think
also this message probably would hit
maybe fathers a lot more because now the
kids they look at their father but the
father never told them like hey get
married early and then the the kid is
like yeah I got to finish college I got
to make my money I got to do this I got
to do that but also you find the sisters
too like I want him I want a G wagon for
a Mah I want 50k and the house in the
blood right that's kind of like
something that you probably seen lately
in one of the reals they created the
asks are are just beyond crazy right so
things are the Haram is getting easier
the will be so hard you have to spend so
much money to just get a Halal
relationship but Haram you just a movie
ticket whatever and then it's done right
it's maybe 100 bucks 20 bucks so they
push this idea to focus on your purpose
but yet be distracted with desire and
those are two do not meet so yeah they
they they really contradict itself so I
think that's why Islam is the solution
not a solution as brother Jael the Roman
say it's the solution because everything
that we is is coming from the Creator
the Creator knows best and we have the
Quran is our manual and our Prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam gave us
Hadith and S and he explained massively
on this uh family Dynamic and all that
don't get married until you're 35 making
six FES a year in shape going to the gym
consistently and have SE with 50 girls
how would you respond to that so what
did he say so this is uh do you know
this brother yeah brother Meer he's a
Muslim brother may Allah guide him to
the again to the true path
inshallah we we want him having these uh
these conversations with us that are
promoting things that are Halal that's
going to bring the blessings of the
crater upon Him upon the um uh but these
statements like this okay don't get
married to your 35 35 what's the other
one six figure six figure what else uh
you got the uh sleeping with as many
women as possible he put a number on
actually 50 yeah 50 yeah uh how what
would you say to him I think his his
assessment to the situation is coming
out of what the Western World and trying
as a human being as much as you think
that you know you don't know because
you're not all knowing and if you are
prescribing things in that in in that
fashion you have to understand the
ramification and the result the results
you're giv man because yeah my my some
men will be like yeah that's actually
what it is because I I am the man I'm
I'm piss because this girl cheated on me
or this but you're already starting off
of the wrong start because you're dating
and dating is absolutely Haram because
you're going from the back doors you're
not coming from the front every man even
actually the Western man who has percept
who's a Christian or who just agnostic
or atheist they would appreciate it if
you come through the front door say
saying that uh hey um I would love to
get to know your daughter and marry her
and this is actually was uncommon to
date and go out and all that stuff until
the 1970 right when the um the uh
feminist uh movement starts and also the
uh invention of the uh pregnancy pills
and it beca provided a safety net for
the poor decisions of women and you can
see the waves of feminism they come one
and second first they want equality then
it become more and more and more until
to be a better man you have to be more
like a woman in today's gynocentric Fe
first female first uh society and even
you can see even with our sisters they
almost became above criticism you can
say anything to a woman you can tell her
you can give n you can
do you can tell them don't do this and
do this this is better for you and this
is what our Prophet sallallah alh
wasallam preaches so I think I think
what I would like to say is and I
watched some of his um videos about
Islam when he actually dive into it and
you can see the sincerity and that he
knows actually what he's saying is
almost like he's trying to customize
something for a certain audience but uh
Allah send Islam to the entire Humanity
not just you can't just Pi can choose
right you can't you can't say like okay
this is going to work for this group but
because they are dating is okay for them
and all this is okay for them yeah make
money get strong be responsible but also
do not V anything that Allah said do not
do don't even come near fornication but
now he's actually incentivizing and if
you uh if you are going to um give
people such advice if people take
actions upon it thinking that you are
actually influenced you taking bad Deeds
through that and you he's got to really
think about that absolutely is this red
is this red pill absolutely yeah this is
red pill theology yes yes they don't say
theology but this is actually become
like a religion almost yes they have one
thing is called the spinning plates it's
a it's a concept they have although the
the writer of the book will defend it
say that spinning plates doesn't mean
that you have to sleep with this woman
that's the term spinning plates spinning
plates yes that means fornicating it's
more like you have to see multiple women
at the same time all dating women at the
same time not in marriage not in
marriage no so it's for it's it's
fornicating yes yes yes yes and it's
almost like you have to kind of look
into your options and until you find a
good woman in a sense yeah let's uh what
are your what are your uh thoughts there
it's really I like what you said because
Allah if you're a Muslim and again we
want the best for this brother and maybe
he's not understanding the impact the
the consequence of a person's actions
you're out there and Allah is saying for
example so it can hit home Allah says
pray five times a day but then you say
you know I'm not you know I'm not a good
Muslim and then you're advising people
not to pray at all I mean what or Allah
is saying get married you're saying
don't get married have 50
so or or you're you have a a wife spouse
at home and you're telling her one thing
and now she's rebelling against you what
are you going to do you're probably
going to in his case he's going to get
rid of her you have a child you're
telling a child what to do you're the
superior and he's disobeying you
rebellious this is your creator when
your creator told you if you want to do
it do it lawfully in marriage and if you
need more two three or four and that's
it there's a limit right there but now
you're saying no you can do 50 you're
going to war with I mean you're like and
this is like it's it's thing you're
you're concealing your sins but now
you're coming up and promoting your own
way yes imagine the ramification against
your creator your creator saying this
way you say no go go right go left go
this way no he say go on the straight
pet what what are your thoughts when you
hear it's very dangerous it is very
dangerous and that's the biggest thing
is that it is very easy for a lot of
young Brothers to become wrapped up in a
lot of this red pill ideology because it
can feel empowering in comparison with
What's called the blue pill the blue
pill is kind of just like you know the
be a part of the system be a cog in the
wheel etc etc follow you know blah blah
blah don't be a man be you know weak
effeminate quiet don't you know try to
excel in life just try not you know like
just all these things don't don't try to
bother anybody just whatever nice guy
syndrome so red pill can be very
enticing for somebody who likes the idea
of no be a rebel start a business go
fornicate with women Etc but there's a
paradigm that's infinitely higher than
that which is the green pill as they
call it or as we have always called it
Islam submission to Allah Allah the one
who created us right so let's say that
you know you bought a car right and some
guy you know some quack mechanic says no
no no forget about the instruction
manual from the manufacturer do this
thing this thing this thing and then all
those things have a lot of consequences
not not only on yourself but also on
society that's what the red pill is
because not only is it consequential to
society negative and detrimental to
society when men go and you know use
women and then discard them Etc because
now you have a lot of women who have
been emotionally scarred in these ways
who then go on to emotionally scar men
cuz hurt people hurt people and before
you know you have a whole generation of
people who are emotionally scarred and
damaged and have baggage and just
creates this very negative relationship
culture we see today and then the red
pill tries to solve it at the same level
the problem was created at no the
problem needs to be solved at a much
higher level which is a level from God
himself the highest level possible the
one who created us who then sent down
the instruction manual in the Quran that
told us what to do what not to do who
sent us our Prophet peace be upon him
sallallahu alaihi wasallam who he told
us to listen to in the Quran so whenever
we listen to any of the authentic
narrations from the prophet peace be
upon him who told us the way to conduct
ourselves with our wives with our
children with our society who told the
women how to conduct themselves with
their husband we don't need to listen to
all these pop culture figures the red
pill or some of the you know feminists
who are speaking to women these days
telling them things that are also
contrary to Islam the red pill is like
the male version of feminism but both of
them sometimes actually I would say
probably most of the time are contrary
to Islam and the Sunnah we just have to
follow Islam and it's a society wide
thing right you know we as Muslims we
have to be very careful when we're
vetting a spouse we can't just you know
marry somebody who subscribes to these
un Islamic ideologies because then it's
not going to be compatible with us when
we're trying to live the dean properly
we have to find somebody who's on the
dean the best way is to find somebody
from a good family who's pre-qualified
having come from a good family who has
good relations with their family who
follows the dean to ask the right
questions our brother jabriel has a
great marriage vetting class absolutely
that both of us would highly recommend
so definitely recommend looking into
that and from there then you can start
to establish the right path and so
that's in with regards to you know a lot
of what the brother myin said and in
addition to that
uh we are actually advised as Muslims to
get married young not to wait till 35
because at 35 I mean you're you hit
puberty 20 years ago you've had a high
sex drive for 20 years there's a lot of
room for error and a lot of room for the
devil for Shan to whisper to us and lead
us astray the devil always makes us
these promises look to the first time
that the devil ever led a human astray
he promised you know Adam and Eve uh the
the tree of you know immortality and
blah blah and God's just trying to
prevent you from this blah blah blah no
God does not operate from a scarcity
mindset God is all abundant right so God
doesn't need to operate from a scar if
God tells us not to do something it's
for our own good God is looking out for
us God loves us God's not trying to
deprive us of anything God rather has
told us not to go astray but yet the
devil tells us no there's some benefit
for you in that there's some benefit for
you in alcohol weed sleeping with women
sleeping with men whatever it may be and
that's how the devil tries to baby step
you and then if you go down the deep end
in that path guess what you even look at
someone like Dan ban uh do you know who
Dan ban is yeah so he's like this uh
massive Playboy and even he had this one
interview where he was saying like Okay
I slept with five women a day and I
realize it's just this honic treadmill
like if if that's the level you're
trying to get to for somebody who's like
you know thinks that the red pillow is
the right way It ultimately is empty Dan
bazan himself said so so if that isn't
enough proof for you that you shouldn't
pursue that path then look at the Quran
itself look at all the truth and the
signs in the Quran all the knowledge
that a man in that Century you know
living in Mecca couldn't have known
right it's impossible that the prophet
peace be upon him could have had all
that you know background knowledge uh in
all these different fields that the
Quran covers and that the tonality could
have been so consistent even some of the
signs that science has only recently
discovered such as you know the exact
Dynamics behind this guy hamon who was
helping the Pharaoh build his pyramids
Allah referenced that in the Quran you
know 1400 years ago and modern science
only descri uh deciphered these
hieroglyphics now so Islam is the truth
on every level just read the Quran
anybody who's never read the Quran just
read it and you'll see exactly what I'm
talking about that's all you need who
this this person you mentioned what's
his name Dan Dan let's have a look at
what he has to say million dollars you
know a lot of people equate money to
happiness and it's not it's more freedom
what people don't understand is like
once you have basic needs met you don't
get incremental happiness for more money
you do for a short period of time like
if you're a $100,000 a year guy and I
bump you to 200,000 you're going to be
happy but that's not going to last
you're going to get used to 200,000 my
problem is you know and a lot of rich
people there's nothing that I buy that
brings me happiness I bought a Ferrari I
wasn't happy for more than 24 hours put
100 miles on the [__] in a year and
got rid of it you know like I just
didn't care I can't get pleasure spikes
anymore being a pleasure Seeker is like
being a drug addict you take a peret
makes you feel good you know now two
weeks later you got to take two perets
to get the same feeling 3 weeks later
you're taking three four five then
eventually you're taking them just to
not feel like [__] and you don't get
high anymore same thing with pleasure
pleasure is like fleeting and pleasure
is one of those things where it's like
it's a black hole you know so what makes
you
happy oh [__] surfing hanging my friends
you know what I mean like this [__] that
doesn't cost money to be honest with you
you know it's kind of funny but like wow
just think about that let that sink in
this is like the new Hugh Hefner pretty
much pretty much modern day social media
he he and and that's the thing it's a
honic treadmill when you chase this
pleasure addiction there's nothing but
more chasing of pleasure it's a
treadmill and the devil just runs you
all day long like that you're running on
this low vibration energy that the devil
feeds you versus when you listen to God
you could be you could have nothing and
you'll be happy because you have the
connection with Allah because you have
that daily fulfillment and guess what
you get that much more blessings in your
life God's going to test you but at the
same time as you pass those tests you
have so so there's another narra from
the prophet which is when uh when things
are going well I'm paraphrasing it when
things are going well say alhamdulillah
all praise is due to God and when things
don't go well have patience and when we
maintain that God's going to give us ups
and downs that's just how life is and
that's how God tests us and that's also
how God keeps us grounded so we're not
on this you know pleasure treadmill so
everything God does is for our own
benefit and so if you have that faith in
God he's going to bless you in all kinds
of ways you didn't anticipate if not in
this life then absolutely in the next
for some like myin or whoever whoever
else uh especially I mean this is
someone who is comes from a Muslim
background Muslim parents we want the
best for the brother but he um he can
instead of throwing out the baby with
the bath water he can make some
adjustments and he can start promoting
let's say because he he had things from
an Islamic perspective that actually are
more conducive to a better Society
better family because promoting what uh
sleeping with 50 women imagine what
you're actually doing to society what
you're actually are you help what father
in his right mind is going to let his
daughter to be someone who's just test
being test driven absolutely so lineage
I mean Islam came to protect lineage how
many illegitimate children from these
men responsibly they're going to go
ahead and obviously to hook up usually
around that culture is alcohol and drug
that's one interesting thing he doesn't
promote alcohol but that's the culture
you know you to pick up a lot of times
you're going to be in the club and a lot
of times so you're not going to be able
to limit and control that anyways it's
just a dark hole ofis black hole henis
Hedonism
psychological um imagine all the
psychological effects that are happening
to the male and the female from all this
100% so he can what do you think he can
start shifting his show towards more he
can start promoting polygyny what's
wrong with that yeah nothing is wrong
with that and I think also there is
something to learn because he's in the
circle of our brother also Andrew Tate
who obvious obviously reach Heights that
many would say so many men would never
be able to in today's time from the fame
from the actually the he captivated the
minds and the hearts of the youth right
you find like literally 9 years old or
even 14 they actually what's your color
of you Bugatti right because they have
heavily influenced and I think he's a
guy who I'm assuming that he's much
wealthier and had reached higher Fame
and he found out that Islam is the way
and he he took a drastic turn to
actually promoting Islam and pro
promoting brotherhoods and promoting
things that they are good for society
after analyzing he's a smart guy his
father is a smart guy and he was
analyzing that hey I had I had slept
with all these girls I have all this
money a I fly private I'm the man I'm
tall I can fight I did all these things
but I'm still empty what's the solution
unlike theeran who went to talk about
surfing and all that stuff he actually
went and said who created this world why
am I in this vehicle that we call life
where is it heading if someone will grab
you and put you on an airplane or even
in a train you will ask the question hey
where are we heading what is this
direction what are we doing why am I
here but no one is actually pushing the
envelope to ask the question and for
brother myin I would
say the person who shows you goodness is
if he he did it so you will get all
these great things switching the message
but understanding that it's it's almost
like you have to have the intentions
right the intentions are the the
standards are the you have to renew your
intentions for goodness you have to
understand listen all this life one day
I'm going to die I have all this content
that is promoting all these things and
it's going to live forever and people
were going to go fornicate why don't I
promote understand the the solution that
Islam provides okay you have a man who's
just wanting to have more than one wife
because by logically a man is designed
to be poist okay well we have polygyny
we can promote that you can explain
maybe to the brothers and also to the
sisters how is a high value man should
percept or or any man who is willing to
take one more wife is okay for him he
could be successful at that absolutely
he's got some skills he's got some good
skills he's really well spoken he's
charismatic he's uh he's he's smart
right and he has all this
characteristics that will help him but
he's already had the brand fresh and fit
right so he will be able to promote a
positive message that actually help
people come closer to Allah because
there is nothing better as a job or a
career than actually calling people to
to the Creator right and that's what I
think he should change his message to or
per se at least just consider it and I
show I saw him in one of the um shows on
Rumble and he was talking about his
Islam and thinking that he knows that
what he's doing and it's funny but
because you can see he's genuine about
knowing that whatever he's saying is not
completely right or even right and he
said one day I will do it well that day
could
be your end date could be actually
before that date that you're deciding
and one thing that I like to say because
they they preach the resilience and
discipline and the goo attitude and
having the uh po uh burden of
performance you have to be a logic too
they are logical individuals that's what
rational male that's what is about it's
all about using your logic yeah I think
that if you use your logic you will
realize that you're actually a weak man
in a sense I'm not calling him a weak
man but a weak man will actually know
the truth and will deny it and that's
actually
even right someone who is arrogant
Subhan right because you you denying
knowledge and you are gifted with
knowledge and I think there is nothing
greater than the gift that Allah let us
know who he is Allah could have in him
in his infinite wisdom to let this ball
just spin in around the Sun and around
itself and not even let us know who he
is but he gifted us with that gift and
we all as I said to brother munir the
the thing that most Muslim Brothers
don't really think about is not to
actually go to Just Jenna because Jenna
is one of his Creations but actually is
to see him to see Allah subh and that's
the ultimate goal insh so I think
promoting a positive message will do
much good one to himself and second to
other people I've had these brothers and
I look at it like these are signs I've
had uh Tam khong good friend of Andrew
Tate he was uh my interviewed him he's
also pushing this um talking about this
lifestyle and whatnot is Haram and all
the other things that go along with it
jeel Antonio sha good brother he's also
was on his show and he's talking about
this life of debauchery and whatnot and
these are signs for an individual
they're right in front of you these are
people you respect who are non-muslim
also and now they're coming out and
speaking out against this so think you
know you want to really reflect and why
deny now this is a beautiful point that
you guys you know are making this truth
is coming to you if you're someone who's
rational thinking and I've heard them
talk I heard him in particular talk
against alcohol mhm right talking pretty
much you know in a in a in a in a very
staunch way against alcohol so don't get
now be man enough now when someone is
telling you about fornication about Zena
which Allah is legislating that people
people burned in ovens man what it this
this is something very dangerous right
this is this is something that you
should really take seriously because
you're now jumping over Allah and saying
No this is good Allah is saying this is
evil yes and you're helping to destroy
society and families and whatnot uh and
we we can go on and unpackage all the
different devastated harms that come I
think it was say um the Conqueror of
Jerusalem um
Saladin he said there's a quote by him
famous quote saying if you want to
destroy a nation of society make
Zen a
pris rap imagine so you're helping yes
this instead of being a real solution
that Allah had given to mankind so you
don't want Allah to smash you because of
this man no you don't want to play
around and you don't want to do what is
called which making the sin uh public
that's one of the most dangerous things
that I see a lot of brothers and a lot
of even sisters in some videos they ask
them how they met and they were talking
about being in a club and all that stuff
hey you don't have to say that you don't
have to mention youri you don't have to
be talking about it and so many men they
get into a conversation about talking
about their past don't talk about it now
you moved on you you don't have to
mention the girl's name you don't have
to be you never know maybe she now she's
a better Muslim maybe you are a better
Muslim so is really really dangerous and
Allah will would will put you in front
and you will literally be asked because
um I I think there is something to do
with the he after they would have a
special uh treatment in which it's not
that great it's not and one thing also
is anything you leave for the sake of
Allah Allah is always going to give you
something better and so I think for a
lot of people including potentially our
brother myON including potentially many
people watching this is they become
addicted to not only the zena itself but
also the identity that they've created
around being somebody who promotes Zena
and is frequently engaging in Zena
because they're trying to attract a
certain type of person so they can have
more Zena right and so it's important to
be able to let go of that emotional
attachment to that identity and start to
realize that there is a much better
identity a much better version of you
that you can become that's infinitely
more fulfilling than the emptiness
you're currently experiencing as a
result of this zenab based identity that
you're trying to promote with your brand
with your actions to the women
themselves so you can have more Zena all
this stuff you have to leave it I know
it's the hardest thing but just consider
the alternative where is your life going
are you going to be 50 60 70 still doing
this you don't think you are but will
you even make it there like brother
hosein said your time could be running
out but I also want you to consider the
alternative which is what if you
continue to live your 30s 40s 50s but
you get on the dean you start to
actually be on the straight path where
you are following the Commandments from
God himself who created who sent down
the manual the uh scripture within which
there is no doubt the Quran if you
actually follow just literally give it a
try I know this sounds like you know a
funny way of saying it some people might
criticize give it a try no you must
commit all the way no literally if if
committing to Islam fully is too much
for you because you're addicted to Zenna
and your identity is wrapped up in Zena
try it for a short period of time try
getting on the dean for a week a month a
year whatever you can commit to and I
promise you I guarantee I swear to Allah
that your life is going to become so
much better that you'll wonder why it
took you so long the only regret you're
going to have is that you didn't realize
this sooner your life's going to be so
much better even when you leave all
these things and Allah's going to give
you something better try one I know
subcrib five times try one time a day go
to Juma try Juma just go to commit I
mean you should be somebody who's
preaching discipline and whatnot and I
like what Andrew Tade our brother says
uh follow the book follow the book so
the book is saying to stay away from
certain things stay away from certain
things we don't want to be Hypocrites
right so this is something that defines
a high value man absolutely yes that's
the that's the number one thing is
having a connection with your Creator
and obeying your creator that's how
that's how you truly show your love and
obedience and um are you are you
imitating because uh this is what and
Allah knows how he
created the things that men desire the
most most wom is are women so Allah gave
you an Avenue go ahead and you can go up
to four and whatnot and this person are
you imitating Dan I don't think
anybody's getting more hookups than than
Dan bazian right right
yeah are you are you trying to compete
with him but he's telling you this is
he's telling you is a dark it's him he's
coming out it's like these are signs
also for you to reflect over isn't that
amazing like he's he's worth I don't
know how many um hundreds of millions
and he's talking about the things that
make it Happ simple things just surfing
and what not hanging with the boys he's
not correct correct he's not talking
about but it's still an empty thing
empty he's like it's empty at the end
you're going to sit on the pillow at
night and you're going to say what am I
doing is this all and I'm going to die
and most most people will actually fear
death when actually a Muslim indeed
should welcome it in any time right
because that's the attachment and also
that's a really important point if you
call yourself a Muslim Islam in the
Arabic term is complete
submission complete submission meaning
that you submit to his orders you submit
to everything you can't just be like
yeah yeah yeah let me let me take this
from the book uh let me H let's do Zena
here you know you you have to take
everything you have to follow everything
right and I'm not saying like if if
you're not following all of it leave it
all that's not what I'm saying what I'm
saying is that you have to follow it all
you have to see because if this is you
you thought this was beneficial what
makes you think that that's not really
beneficial because all of them are
coming from the same you know Source
it's Allah subhana Our God so you have
to take everything Al together do not be
just choosing this and choosing that and
choosing this in a way and become like
this is work Works to my advantage but
this one doesn't really because I really
like that girl and I'm looking at her
and she actually looking really good and
she's coming to talk to me so no
everything all works together and as we
said before changing the message will
work massively he's connected with some
brothers that actually they were Western
he grew up as a Muslim in the household
and now they're coming on his show
telling that Islam is the way and that's
a look at that yes and at some level
that's not coincidence yes it's not and
maybe that's that's Allah sending him
these people saying like hey the the
truth is Islam and you're away from it
and you have a huge platform when you
can have a great impact on not only the
Muslim Community you can have a huge
impact on non-muslims because those are
the people who are hurt basically the
most because they do not know any better
they have this um I would like to call
it not the ability to question their
epistemology and the
pomology is the um the study of or the
coming to knowledge in a way so they
don't even sit and think why we are here
why am I doing the things that I'm doing
why am I fornicating is it good for me
why am I drinking alcohol why am I uh
not seeking something else you sit down
you read you collect books you just read
as brother M just open just open the
Quran it's so easy learn about the
Muslims try to not be be a victim of
this programming that Islam is bad is
oppressive to women and this you know
this uh all the mens are really
aggressive and they have but look at the
world the most rapid uh growth of any
religion is Islam and the majority of
people staying there in their practice
and that's the beauty of it so I think
at the end of the day he just had to sit
down with himself and be absolutely
honest because a man who lies to himself
will cheat anyone and lot of people say
I want an honest man and I'm honest and
I'm completely sincere but you're
failing with the one who created you so
how sincere are you and how honest are
you very deep something something to
think about and I like that and for for
people who just accepted Islam you know
obviously step by step there's a
difference you know between you know
coming in and acknowledging I have to do
this yes to become someone who is in
line with my purpose step by step but
now if I am having a hard time
implementing something don't go and
promoting the things that you're
supposed to be staying away from and
conceal the sins conceal it conceal it
not now by day you sin that by night
time you're promoting it because you're
spreading it to other people so and then
go ahead and keep turning back because
Allah is the most loving the most kind
the most merciful keep turning back and
step by step making progress to
eventually you're away from the things
you're away you're completely safe and
you now now you're establishing Salah
five times a day
theb for us out of good for us people
don't it's good for us it's good for
Humanity find me one thing that Allah
had ordained that's not good for us or
he prohibited and now it's not something
that's harmful MH you might not no but
things get uncovered you're like wow
correct this is something that actually
it's a blessing that we are told to stay
away from it 100% yes yeah we covered a
lot Brothers this is alhamdulillah this
can be a benefit to so many
people and uh where can people now if
they want to go ahead and hook up with
you guys and learn more on health and
fitness yes so I have an Instagram page
the modern Muslim man um posts a lot of
uh knowledge and you know tips that you
can apply whether you're Advanced
whether you're a beginner so inshallah
you can find me on Instagram we also
have YouTube but Instagram I post every
day so inshallah hopefully it's
beneficial you can find me on Instagram
it's hen. based uh YouTube as well Tik
Tok and uh I have two sites is one
isa.com and another one is Prim
tonic.com and that's where most likely
you will find me may Allah God Almighty
Allah the Creator bless you both a nice
talking with you brother
abely thank you for having us I cannot
leave without giving you a gift if
you're not yet Muslim and you tuning in
to see what these Muslims are talking
about and you like a free copy of the
Quran go ahead and visit theen show.com
we'll take care of the postage and
everything and get it delivered to you
and if you still have some questions
about Islam call us at 1 1800
66247 52 we'll see you next time until
then peace be with you assalam alaykum